a defense for a portion of beginning  well during case he can talk all he  wants I think the biggest voice there  nice bounce pass from the blog to AE  three-point attempt missed and LeBron  has Welker ahead of the field  [Applause]  you fit the Flip Saunders legacy  boundaries now the shoes today  the thing wrong with Westbrook going  against a bead expressed that James and  Durant and others in the league are  certainly free to express the political  opinion that comes to rant perfect this  is the banjo with Jim be trying to carve  out  [Applause]  brought back jackson twin bead westbrook  20 moves on DeRozan  [Music]  people certainly meeting Kenneth I have  procession Westbrook gets ahead of a  field outreach  an absolute elegant man are going to  celebrate look at that they just won the  backyard championship the playground  championship the best pick-up day you'll  see